these are some celebrities that other
celebrities said that they're crushing
on Kim Kardashian recently said that her
ultimate Crush Was JFK Jr Olivia Rodrigo
said her biggest celebrity crush of all
time is Bruce Springsteen Blake Lively
said her childhood Crush was David
Letterman Meryl Streep said her
celebrity crush was Will Ferrell
honestly if they were ever a pair it
would kind of make sense to me and LL
Cool J said his celebrity crush is Meryl
Streep Jennifer Lawrence has a celebrity
crush on Larry David he's really funny I
kind of get it Adele once said her
celebrity crush is Zach Galifianakis she
said if someone can make her laugh their
husband material Ricky Martin said his
first celebrity crush was John Travolta
and Nicole Kidman said she had a crush
on Jimmy Fallon and also that she was
expecting him to ask her out but that he
never made a move